what's up you guys once again it's movie
retrospective time going back to the
1970s
this is kind of uh one i don't really
hear a lot of people talking about i
remember seeing it i forgot all about it
yeah this is i think the first time that
i heard about this it's rituals from
1977. i think the first time i heard of
this was in the stephen king book dance
macabre
and he didn't really like talk about it
at length but it was in
he had like an index in the back of the
book where he kind of recommended
a hundred really good movies this was
pre-1980
uh and ones that he thought didn't
really get seen enough and this one was
on there now when we were watching it
last night though i was like when we got
to the one part like particularly around
the climax part where they were like on
the ridge
uh i remembered a lot of that so i must
have seen it at some point in the past
and you know because it sounded so
familiar and the reason this is this is
so weird like the reason that i put it
in the patreon poll
was because shutter just added it
because i think it got released on
blu-ray not too long ago
but then for whatever reason we couldn't
get shutter to work last night like it
just kept like sitting there and we
couldn't get anything out of it so we
ended up having to watch
a free one that someone had uploaded to
youtube which was okay but it looked
like it had been transferred from vhs
and it was like really really dark so
you couldn't really see it blurry
yeah you can really see what's going on
toward the end so i had to kind of we
had to kind of like squint at it and
then i had to kind of go and read all
the
plot synopsis so i could figure out what
the [ __ ] was going on because some of
the [ __ ] you couldn't see
but yeah this is actually it's a
canadian movie
and i think what ended up happening with
this one um it got dismissed a lot
because i think at the time people just
thought oh it's a canadian deliverance
ripoff which it's not really
um and also something that happened too
like when it came out it's sort of like
the distribution was just very
lackluster so it just kind of
didn't really go anywhere you know what
i'm saying i can see what they're
talking about with it being uh like
deliverance it was like deliverance it
was that same kind of idea dude dudes
out in the wilderness and they're not in
their environment they run into some bad
[ __ ] yeah i mean the setup is
the same yeah but this it almost in the
way this is structured it's almost
structured more like a slasher movie
yeah than deliverance yeah they don't
run into hillbillies per se think of it
as like they more like they run into
jason basically yeah except it's a real
dude but yeah yeah it's a dude like bent
for revenge type of thing so that's in
that sense it's more like an 80s slasher
yeah but he is like jason in some ways
yeah definitely yeah and this really has
man this had like an all-star cast like
the guy that directed it peter carter i
guess he hadn't really done a lot he
worked like a lot of he did like tv
movies and stuff he did um like a
klondike fever an adaptation of that
which is a jack london book uh like i
said he did some tv stuff but he died in
like 1982.
um but yeah this has kind of like a sort
of like an all-star cast or at least
like a lot of
really good like sort of recognizable
actors but really good character actors
uh hal holbrook is kind of like the main
character he's classing at the joint
class and up the joint and hal holbrook
spent like a million things i still love
him from creep show man yeah but uh
lawrence dane was in this too i think
nowadays he's probably best known for
bride of chucky but he's been a bunch of
other stuff too and robin gamel who was
in this he played martin i think and i
kept like the whole movie i was kind of
like where have i seen that [ __ ] before
he's like so [ __ ] uh he's so [ __ ]
familiar and when i looked up his
wikipedia page he was actually the one
of the like the creepy dude from the
haunting of julia aka full circle which
i've seen a bunch of times and i was
like oh well that's where i've seen him
before he was also in a movie called
nightmares from 1983 that anthology
movie i think emilio estevez was at that
i need to see that again i remember the
only the only uh portion of that i
remember is the bishop of battle like
the killer video game thing so i don't
even remember like what the other
stories were i gotta write that down so
we gotta see that but yeah so i can kind
of see where it comes off it's like oh
it's kind of like deliverance because
what you have
is five guys
and they're all doctors in varying
capacities one's like this hot shot
surgeon uh one used to be a surgeon but
couldn't hack it anymore so now he's a
general practitioner
one is kind of like um because at the
beginning aren't they like talking about
i'm gonna do like dick filler kind of
stuff like he's just he's just trying to
like do because i think medical ethics
is like a big theme of this movie
because i think that kind of turns out
to be what the guy is stalking them
about sort of
yeah which i kind of find that that boy
isn't that convenient
that there's a dude with a grudge
against doctors just happens to be out
there and just happens to find some
doctors
i don't i well i don't really know
because the the five doctors they it you
know it's set up in the movie that they
do like a wilderness trip like every
year like it's a kind of bonding thing
but i don't know if they necessarily go
to the same place because what's the
chances of there being a dude out there
kind of like jason who hates doctors
yeah well you know like i said it's like
a slasher movie in the sense that you
don't like really think about it too
much it's it's it's a good movie the
tone in some ways kind of reminds me for
some weird reason like duel remember
duel yeah kind of that's kind of what
but it but it looks like a vietnam movie
from the time
there's a lot of [ __ ]
vietnamese
type terrain and guys with [ __ ]
black kind of like soot on their faces
to make like they're getting dirty but
it looks like camouflage to me
and they're
walking through the damn forest trying
to survive being
hunted down by the
this [ __ ] dude they never see him not
until the end until the very end and it
just kind of reminds me
of like imagine if duel had not one dude
versus a truck but a truck versus like
five dudes
except the truck is the first truck is a
person
on a road they're out of the woods no
there's just something they're really
not like but no i know what you're
saying
and i think what it is is because it's
the movie's mostly about like the
tension of the unknown you never see the
truck driver so maybe that's the part of
the kind of spoiler alert for duel yeah
you only see his arm that's the only
thing they did that also with the car
yeah which is the the drive like yeah
the car was the devil so you never
really saw inside you know they opened
the window dude looked he saw the [ __ ]
was oh but you never see what he saw
right you know and it was like a lot of
that kind of [ __ ] in it in a certain way
but i kind of get that and like i said i
kind of like this one
this one i thought was like really good
because not only it you know and it did
kind of like that really good thing that
you know decent horror movies do where
it's like they set up the tension
between all your main characters like
before you even get to
you know the bad [ __ ] or the person
that's stalking them so they not only
have that to contend with but they also
have kind of like nature to contend with
which you know is sort of augmented by
the person that's stalking them but they
for a long time they don't know who it
is that's stalking them or why they're
stalking them and you know so there's
kind of like a red herring kind of
situation too which i'll get into in a
minute
but yeah so you have these five doctors
like i said um you know they're they
kind of like establish a little bit of
their personalities and like how their
ethics and morality and stuff like that
differ so because that'll play into the
story later on yeah some are good guys
some are [ __ ] cowards and [ __ ] you
know yeah yeah like i said so um you
know and it's kind of established
they've been friends a long time they do
this every year when dudes one dude's
obsessed with other people being
alcoholics when he himself i think is
alcohol just talking about people being
on the sauce and salt what sauce artists
no juice artists juice artists that's
what it is yeah the first time that he
said that like he called somebody a
juice artist i'm like is that a heroin
addict
but then later on when they because i
had never heard that phrase but then
later on like they said something else
and in context i said oh he must be like
an alcoholic he's worried about other
people drinking there's a lot of
alcoholism going on in this movie
something that i didn't really realize
this didn't really stick out to me and
this was kind of like a this is kind of
like a big thing for 1977. one of the
characters i think it was martin uh is
gay but they don't
which one was that he was um the one he
he was the one that was like contending
i guess with uh hal holbrook i think
that's the one that i were talking about
and it's like i think it's only
mentioned like one time or it's brought
up and i was like wow that's like
actually kind of cool that it's just
kind of like in there and nobody really
brings it up so i thought that was kind
of neat it's like that doesn't really
happen much in 70s movies usually it's
like
the the character is gay and that's like
the only
character trait or it's like the butt of
a joke still he's gonna flame the [ __ ]
out right but it's like i didn't it's so
subtle that i didn't even like realize
until i was reading a plot synopsis and
i was like oh yeah i guess so it's like
it didn't even stand out well they're
all doctors so they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah so yeah nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah so
they go to this place um in northern
ontario so like i said this was a
canadian movie they shot this for only
six hundred thousand dollars and i think
most of those actors did almost all of
their own stunts which if you see this
movie
is pretty impressive i have to say i'm
sure i would not if i was an actor i'd
be like no thanks i'll be in my trailer
but um yeah get somebody else to do it
but so they go to this place and it's
called don't they say it's called the
cauldron of the moon right because they
said like the indigenous tribes in the
area like they have a legend that the
moon like bumped into the earth at that
point and like made this big huge like
chasm and it has like this river down in
the middle um so that there's kind of
like something made of that like you
know how they're saying oh the
indigenous tribes they say it's like big
medicine and it's supposed to be like
magic and then when they're all drunk
later on around the fire they make jokes
about what if this place really was
magic and what it is that the other so
uh so yeah it's all that so they get
dropped off by a plane
and then they uh go and they do their
first campsite they all get drunk one of
them inexplicably has brought a blow-up
doll um
i guess so but it just seems like
just just a pro tip when you're going
into the wilderness where there's like
literally nothing else and no one else
around
probably you should use the room that
that would take up to take something
more useful it was inflatable though i'm
just saying
but it's like you could have like the
room that that took up you could have
taken a whole other roll of toilet paper
you could have taken an extra pair of
shoes i think which does come up i think
they were i think
i think
it was just a gag i know but it was just
something that i was swimming you know
because they were like sitting around
the fire drinking and i was like for
real did he just did he bring a blow-up
doll he's blowing up a blow-up doll and
you're out the fire and i was just like
okay you do you whatever um and i love
the like the one guy who's the drunky
he's basically like they go in his pack
later on because like some of their
packs get lost it's like basically all
that's in his pack is toilet paper and
scotch
and i'm like it's always funny but
what's funny about blow up dogs
is that when you see them at the gag
store they say blub doll and on the
[ __ ]
on the on the packaging they show a
photograph of a real woman
but there you see it all blown up it
just looks like a [ __ ]
looks like a flotation device
[Laughter]
well see this is well this was the 70s
when they didn't have like the blow up
doll technology they didn't like the sex
doll technology yeah they didn't have
the
blob dolls were always gags
yeah i did anyone i'm sure some people
really use them for their intended
purpose
because it's a big world out there yeah
but i think they were gags but most i'm
sure 99 of them were bought as jokes
yeah as you just give to some dude who
couldn't get laid
[Laughter]
or like you know i i've seen them like
blown up and kind of like put on back
you motor on the back of your motorcycle
or something like that or like at
bachelor parties and stuff like that
i've seen that kind of [ __ ] so yeah so
so they get dropped off there they're
hanging out drinking with the with the
blow up doll and uh when they wake up
the next morning they find that
inexplicably all of their boots are
missing hmm
wonder who could have taken that so uh
so one of them whose name is dj and i
guess he was the one that organized the
trip and we should note is the only one
that was smart enough to actually bring
an extra pair of shoes
because he yells at them he's kind of
like i sent you like guys like a xerox
thing all you had to bring yeah he's
like all you had to bring was toilet
paper i think he said toilet paper and
an extra pair of shoes and it's like you
[ __ ] couldn't even handle that and he
gets really pissed off what's funny
though is having somebody been in the
infantry [ __ ] and you know been in
the worst [ __ ] possible environments
in korea and [ __ ] the middle east and
[ __ ] i challenge these [ __ ]
here one to keep toilet paper dry
especially civilian toilet paper well no
there is no dry toilet paper by the end
of this
no military toilet pepper comes sealed
in a damn pack from your mres and uh you
don't open that until you're gonna use
it so i think it's funny
just civilians bring toilet paper and
they gotta [ __ ] roll the toilet paper
yeah that'll last and that'll
look i'm dumb and i would even like at
least put the [ __ ] in a plastic bag or
something jeez don't just put it in
there it'll get it's humid in florida
yeah even in a ziploc bag it wouldn't
last long well like i said it's better
than just like throwing it in there with
nothing around it for christ especially
in the environment that they were in you
couldn't do a river crossing and water
just makes its way into everything
eventually that's what i'm saying maybe
it's because i grew up in florida where
you like better whereas the air is wet
right so it's like even if you took it
outside yeah outside it would get wet so
you have to do something to like prevent
that from happening what's so much
better is those damn baby wipes
yeah yeah and they take up less room too
yeah i mean depending on how many that
tube
should take the baby wipes and then we
had 200 mile an hour tape sealing it the
lid closed so the moisture couldn't get
out nothing could get in and then you
pull the [ __ ] tape off and [ __ ]
use them and then put it as a shower
[ __ ] toilet paper and a shower in a
[ __ ] plastic
there you get a plastic foot it does
everything it does everything
thank you makers of baby although mres
help out because uh
the turd just falls out like a damn
brick you can hardly need any damn
toilet paper for that that might be too
much information
greasy brick
they're designed for that [ __ ]
they learned that they learned that [ __ ]
from the astronauts giving those
astronauts food
i love that like the when the astronauts
come back to earth and they get
debriefed so how was the [ __ ] yeah
the [ __ ] did yeah
single piece and just lubricated as well
i mean i know it's gross but that is
information yeah that you need to know
and it does make people's lives better
like on down the line so i know it's
like space age [ __ ] but i know it's
funny but yeah it's it's good that they
ask them that kind of stuff so uh so dj
uh after excoriating everybody for not
bringing extra shoes like he told them
to uh he's the only one that has extra
shoes he's like all right so the rest of
you [ __ ] just [ __ ] stay here he's
like i think there's a hydro dam uh not
far from here like a few miles from here
i think what was it 15 miles did they
say it was 15 miles i don't remember how
far it was but he said there's a there's
a hydro dam maybe there's somebody there
i'm gonna hike there and see if we can
you know get some help or get some other
shoes or something like that so he takes
off
now the rest of them
they're basically like uh the next
morning like they like he leaves and
then the next morning they start getting
like even more alarmed because i think
they're in the same uh campsite but when
they wake up they find this really weird
ritualistic type of thing that's like a
stick and it's like a deer head and then
there was like a snake around it i
didn't realize this when i was watching
it but i was reading the plot synopsis
they said oh it's it looks like a
caduceus thing you know what i mean like
the
rod of asclepius or whatever um so yeah
so that's what that was meant to
represent so at that point they're like
okay um somebody's [ __ ] with us now
because dj has gone off and what dj i
think one of the other guys there is
that guy's brother so that causes more
tension because everybody's like well
it's got to be dj like [ __ ] with us
and like doing a joke and stuff like
that and the brother i think his name is
abel is like um yeah he wouldn't do that
so they have like a bunch of fights
about that but they're like well
regardless if it's somebody else then we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here because
somebody is like doing some creepy [ __ ]
like right around while we're sleeping
and that's not cool
so um so at that point they kind of they
start kind of trekking away they none of
them have shoes so i think they wrap all
their uh feet in like rags and plastic
bags and [ __ ] like that
and then uh there's kind of a thing
where
they somebody sees like a like a person
kind of like at the top of this ridge
but then like this person throws like a
beehive on them yeah and one of them i
think it's abel
um is like thrown
he either falls or is thrown off this
ridge and breaks his neck on the way
down so he dies
um at this point they're still thinking
that maybe dj is [ __ ] with them not
that he meant to kill the dude but that
you know
that each maybe it just happened
accidentally but like i said so a lot of
tension about that they basically now
they leave that dude behind right they
don't like take the body with them they
just leave that guy there
um
so they so they basically are like okay
[ __ ] it and then they just keep going
and then they have this whole other
thing where um they they find this rope
that's across the river
so like stretched across so they're like
okay well dj must have been here and he
left this here so we'd know where he was
so they start going across the river on
this rope but it turns out that somebody
has peppered the bottom of the river
with little bear traps
and one of them steps in it
and it breaks their leg that's martin i
think he's the drunk
yeah
uh yeah so it breaks their leg now at
this point
one of the dudes mitzi
it's actually not martin it's mitzi and
uh harry who's played by hal holbrook
those are kind of the two
that are sort of left at the end and
they're the ones that are at odds all
the time because mitzi is the one that's
like cowardly
um martin i think was the gay guy and he
was the one in the drunk and he was the
one that got like his leg broken by the
bear trap if i'm remembering correctly
so at this point they're like okay
they're still kind of like well did dj
do this it was like d why would dj do
something like that like you know he'd
break your leg or whatever and at this
point mitzi is kind of like well you
know martin's leg is broken and we can't
really like go any further with him
because we're gonna have to carry him
and harry is very adamantly because
harry is kind of like represents like
the very upright moral he's like we
can't leave him behind you know what i
mean he's still alive um so he makes
them
like build a stretcher and they
basically float the dude down the river
and there's all that they get in a fight
and then like the dude is like floating
down the [ __ ]
he's gonna go over the [ __ ] falls or
whatever it's like this whole situation
and i was just kind of laughing because
the dude's drunk and he's cause you know
he's in a lot of pain and he's like
floating away on the stretchers the two
other guys are like punching each other
because of like various [ __ ] like got an
argument i was just like really you guys
are just gonna let your friend kind of
you guys are having a slap fight and
he's gonna go over the [ __ ] waterfall
but yeah so that's that whole thing so
uh basically at this point to the guy uh
you know the one with the broken leg
he's like laying there and then the next
morning they find that somebody has been
in their camp again
and has left like a world war ii era
medal
on the front of martin's little sleeping
bag or whatever
and at this point i think they're they
also leave like some discharge papers
and there's like an x-ray or something
so at this point they're starting to
suspect okay well obviously this isn't
dj this is somebody that has a grudge
against doctors um you know maybe a
doctor [ __ ] him over at one point he
found out we were doctors by from
watching us
and yeah see that's the thing i don't
think that the guy
like yeah it's coincidental but i mean
the guy was watching them for a while
because they do that whole like pov
thing like they do in stalker movies so
the guy was obviously like listening to
them talking like for a really long time
before he decided he was gonna do
anything [ __ ] up to them i think i
mean that's
that was the impression that i got
he's like oh well here's these dudes in
the woods oh and they happen to be
doctors when i'm gonna go like in there
and [ __ ] with them i kind of think
that's what happened so so yeah so this
guy obviously has a grudge against
doctors and
it kind of wants them to
figure out like what his beef is i guess
where he's like leaving all these little
clues and stuff so like x-rays and
whatnot now uh so they get to the dam
and then they find that dj
made it to the dam but then it looked
like somebody kind of like nailed him to
a chair and like tortured him and stuff
and he's like sitting up there at which
point mitzi is like let's get the [ __ ]
out of here
and uh harry's like we can't leave him
like this because he thought he was dead
at first but then he was like still but
then he moved and he was like still
alive and he's like dude this he's all
[ __ ] up we can't leave him like that
so harry had to like strangle him and
then at that point mitzi
[ __ ] he's like yeah i'm out
and uh harry's like hey i can't carry
martin on the stretcher like all by
myself and he's just like yeah bye good
luck with that um and harry's just like
[ __ ] me so he actually ends up having to
drag i mean he end up like dragging
martin into the like inside where the
dam is and he's just kind of like you
know i can't take him any further he's
like i'm gonna go get help and
everything like that but then it turns
out that martin's dead and it was like
that was lucky's yeah but that was the
thing you didn't know how long he had
been dead like he could have been dead
for a really long time and they were
just like dragging his corpse around but
uh you know so there's that whole thing
actually before that happens um there's
that great scene which is i think the
main scene that i remembered from this
like the first time i was seeing it
where they're up on the ridge and
they're both carrying
uh martin on the stretcher and they fall
asleep and when they wake up
um their friend that died of the broken
neck like earlier on like somebody left
his head on a pike
like on at their campsite
and i love it like harry just took the
head and was just like flying like he
throws it off the [ __ ] yep i don't
want to look at that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
because at first i was like wait whose
head is that but then i remembered that
the guy whose neck that
had broken like down the hill they left
their bodies who that was too yeah and
then i was like oh i think that's able
that's the guy
yeah that's that guy that fell down the
hill that was his head so that guy's
been like keeping the head the whole
time
so at that point so like i said now
they're separated so harry stumbles into
this uh
cabin
and inside the cabin at first it's like
he starts like pulling stuff like i said
the end of it was really dark and i
think
even up until recently all transfers of
this like the climax because i've seen
other people complaining about it the
climax of it is really really dark they
said you can see it in the theater but
on most home media at least up until the
most recent one you couldn't really see
what was going on it was like really
really dark and really muddied
so it looks like he goes into the
into the cabin and then there's like i
guess it's what like beef jerky or i
don't know what it is i don't know what
it is but he's like pulling it off the
ceiling and eating it and then this old
guy comes in and he starts attacking the
old guy because he's he finds like all
their boots and stuff like in the cabin
and then he finds out that this old guy
is blind so obviously this isn't the
dude who's been [ __ ] with them the
whole time his name is jesse but then it
turns out that it's jesse's brother
that has been doing all this stuff
um
and i guess what i think what ended up
happening
was that uh the brother
i can't remember what the brother's name
is matthew matthew
so matthew i guess was all [ __ ] up
and deformed and stuff like that in the
war
and he had wanted a doctor to
essentially euthanize him so he wouldn't
have to live like that
but the doctors just wanted to keep him
alive for whatever reasons they could
like squeeze because that was like a
discussion that a lot of the guys had
earlier on like when do you know when to
let a patient go you can't just like
leave them
hanging on like forever just so you can
like squeeze more money out of them or
whatever so i kind of feel like the the
reason that the guy was pissed off was
because that he had wished that the
doctors let him die instead of letting
him live like that because he's all like
[ __ ] up looking
so he also burns mitzi to death nobody
feels too bad about that because mitzi
was kind of a dick um
yeah i mean that last whole scene where
harry's in the in the cabin and then
mitzi is like hanging like out in the
yard and matthew i guess is kind of like
building a fire around him or whatever
he's like he's gonna burn me he's gonna
barbie and then like mitzi keeps like
yelling at harry to come help him
meanwhile harry has had like his leg his
legs artery and his leg like stabbed by
matthew and he's trying to like
cauterize it so dude he doesn't use it
yeah he blows his leg he's like
but um you know and mitzi is out there
it's just like he's trying to be nice at
first he's like i'm sorry about all this
[ __ ] i said it
come out here you bastard god damn it
i'm gonna die blah blah and i'm just
like you know what just just let him die
then harry just keeps going shut up shut
up shut up because he's trying to like
[ __ ] fix his like i'll i'll be with
you in a moment but uh it doesn't work
mitzi gets burned to death and like i
said no one's all that upset about it
and uh so harry actually does manage to
uh
you know kind of save the day or win the
day rather he doesn't save the day
because everybody dies but he actually
does manage to get away and he gets to a
road um and just basically sits there
went for a car and i said at the end
he's like sit there in the middle of the
road i said would it be sad right now if
he just like got hit by a bus like
something just went by and [ __ ] like
that but yeah so
as you can see
even though the setup of this is i will
admit very similar to deliverance uh you
know it's five guys friends and they're
out in the wilderness and they're being
stalked by something but like i said
it's like deliverance but it's like a
stalker version of deliverance you can
also say it's almost like predator no
guns
you can say it was like that too yeah
that too yeah
no i'm just saying that you know um and
the the i think like the the climax part
at the end where harry's like fighting
the deformed dude in the cabin that's
also been kind of compared to like straw
dogs the sam peck and pawn movie which
yeah i can see that so yeah this was
actually i think it was made for less
than a million dollars or six hundred
thousand canadian
um and like i said
yeah and i mean and like i said most of
that the actors uh did almost all of
their own stunts
and it just seemed like but when they
made it
it just seemed like the distributors of
it were just kind of like eh
and they didn't really do any so it took
like a really long time like i said it
played in some theaters like in a
limited capacity in canada in the us
but then even on like vhs because i
remember seeing the vhs cover back in
the day but even when it was out on dvd
and [ __ ] like that like it seemed like
the transfer was kind of shitty um and
kind of muddy but i think just maybe a
couple years ago uh or maybe more
recently than that they did actually put
out um a blu-ray
that i think it was scorpion releasing
and they and it's actually like
remastered and i've heard from other
reviews they said it's slightly slightly
scratchy because they had to use from
the original print and that's all they
had but they said other than that it's
it looks pretty good you know what i
mean and that's probably like the best
it's ever going to look because
you know it just got kind of [ __ ] over
and nobody really gave that much of a
[ __ ] kind of a forgotten movie it is and
uh like i said so it's kind of cool like
i said i'd heard the title
um you know from stephen king bringing
it up i'm pretty sure i
and i yeah i thought i hadn't seen it
but when it got to that scene of the
ridge with the head on the stick i'm
like no i did see this because i
remembered the head on the stick and i
remembered them arguing over whether
they should leave the dude on the on the
stretcher behind i remembered that whole
sequence
um so i said okay well i must have seen
this at some point but i just like i
probably just watched it on youtube
because sometimes i'll put on youtube
like some of those channels that have
like forgotten 70s movies and i'll just
kind of have it going on in the
background so i must have seen it like
in that capacity i kind of remembered
the scene where they got their when they
woke up and their boots were gone
yeah and remembered that that's about
that's the only thing i kind of
remembered unless this maybe it's
reminding me of something else but but
it's kind of i saw this movie it's kind
of a shame because i think one of the
best things about this movie like i said
it's not it's called a slasher movie
it's sort of a slasher movie but not
exactly
um i guess it's kind of like a
psychological slasher movie in the sense
that they have somebody stalking them
that's doing like [ __ ] up [ __ ] tonight
that's a decent flick it is it's
actually pretty decent and um you know
considering some of the other stuff that
came out in the 70s like like i said
there was a lot of really good stuff but
there was a lot of kind of trash as well
and it seemed kind of sad you know i
feel like canadian films in general are
not
not usually the things that people jump
to at first other than you know black
christmas is probably the best it wasn't
70s trash oh not at all no this was uh
you know up there with
like i said duel
the island no not quite as big budget as
the island but similar remember uh with
what's his name [ __ ] um david warner
michael caine michael caine yeah
uh similar up up you know deliverance
that ty that type of movie yeah and i
think one of the best things about this
um is
the acting and the character interplay
like i really liked
um yeah i really liked a lot of the
dialogue and i really liked a lot of the
interplay between the characters um and
it's just i don't know it was just like
a really good
because it's almost kind of like had a
psychological thing to it and then there
was like a wilderness survival [ __ ] too
and it goes like um uh
lord of the flies kind in a certain way
they all start turning on each other a
little bit yeah kind of feral and [ __ ]
it's pretty good yeah because and like i
said i like i think they did a good job
of making the characters likeable but
also really flawed and i think they it
was really good like they economically
set up
everyone's sort of world views and how
they conflicted with one another i think
they did that like in a really good like
a naturalistic kind of way i would like
to have seen a better print
yeah like i said there as far as i know
yeah that's um the the version that's on
shutter they just added that so that
must be the newest like definitive
version yeah i'd like to go ahead and
it's kind of a shame that we couldn't
get shutter to load last night so we
couldn't watch the good ones so we had
to watch kind of like a shitty muddy one
that was on youtube it wasn't terrible
but you couldn't really see like when it
was dark you couldn't really see much of
what was going on so i think there's two
different versions of them but they're
this two different people have posted
this i think twice on youtube
yeah up there for free oh and uh and
stay away from there was another version
of this called the creeper
um which is the same movie except with
11 minutes cut out of it yes you might
as well uh so don't bother yeah i think
that was for us release uh i don't know
why they would cut 11 minutes out
but because this isn't trying to make it
pg or something i guess this isn't a
super gory movie i mean there's there's
a there's a severed head and there's
like [ __ ] like that but and there's
violence but it's not i don't know it's
not like super gory or anything so i
don't really know what 11 minutes they
would taken out but whatever uh but yeah
so definitely if you have shutter
and you like kind of like survival
horror you like deliverance you like
kind of 70 slashers or anything like
that this is one that doesn't really get
a lot of
attention and it's definitely worth it
like i said it's got really good actors
in it and it's just i don't know i
enjoyed it quite a bit uh so yeah check
it out if you have shutter like i said
the youtube one is
passable but not that great so i would
recommend watching it on shutter or
getting the blu-ray uh and that will do
it for this movie retrospective we will
see you guys on the next one bye
you